mais si régime
non ça va habiter leurs hôtes à
galanterie t'honore tu es vraiment
exceptionnel armée nous voyons bout de
temps maintenant je sais rien on july
je ne sais pas si vous connaissez
l'oeuvre d'origine les régine c'est sa
nounou à la sortie vous attendez
oui
cours
hé hé
à occasion papier au wifi soit pas qui
lui barre m
si tu attends les diamants loto vous
bien vu
après
chaque
à
khalifa
quand vient le mari
mais c'est bien
il a
et puis à minuit
tous
quel est ton nom
au bout
bush comme les oeufs
dakhli
si les mots sont un peu
mais non
fair play
j'ai là
à voir
lyon à deux euros
il ya les bleus pas mal d'ados
non l'italie
ah non
à paris le depor
y a des
shalimar l'épisode caps torride
mme wade
de fait le taux du temps
mattioli sa fille lila
et gym un régime 74 ans vous reprenez
votre carrière de chanteuse que vous
aviez délaissé quand le monde entier
vous réclamez dans vos boîtes de nuit
voilà vous avez un petit peu oublier la
chanson pendant pendant quelques années
vous revenez aujourd'hui en force
l'album s'appelle made in paname
là
bye
voilà sa belle dispute alors c'est avec
pierre palmade qui sera d'ailleurs le
metteur en scène de votre retour sur
scène alors dispute c'est une chanson
qui est qui est dédié un petit peu aux
femmes battues un régime c'est vrai et
c'est une chanson qui a été fait il ya
1100 par l'autre sernhac ouais ouais
c'est un grand publiciste pas sûr du
tout normalement pour toi qui ne tourne
toujours et j'y vois là donc régine
cette chanson s'appelle disputent un
c'est une chanson dédiée aux femmes
battues et vous avez été vous régine une
femme battue entre 30 et 35 ans vous
viviez avec un type qui était un ex
droguée que j'étais mieux l'alcool y
avait un petit peu changé de drogue et
qui vous frappe et c'est en hommage
cette frappe est différent et non non
non égalité
non le jour je me suis réveillé c'est
quand je clic tout d'un coup je lui à
deauville jeu je me suis rendu compte
que j'étais nu et cavale est dans les
mains et que j'étais en jeu ne s'est en
fait le courrier après lui je me suis
dit oh la la
avec la carrière que tu veux faire et
devenir une star il faut 8 rentrée
alors oui la mpa et régla pas mal moi je
vous l'avait larguée j'ai quand même
duré cinq ans un ouvrier c'était un type
formidable
6 il s'appelle le syndrome de stockholm
ce petit format frappe
vous avez déclaré à france-soir
récemment à 74 ans je fais encore
beaucoup l'amour
il le sait votre mari nous on ex mari
dans quelques temps ouais 34 ans de
fidélité
j'ai décidé nous avons décidé d'un
commun accord de nous de nous tromper de
nous séparer ah oui enfin je m'attends
dans la plus grande émission ça dort il
pouvait bah oui oui bien sûr non c'est
vrai que telle à mal vendredi le met
plus convaincant non non c'est pas ça
c'est que en fait vous avez vécu trente
quatre ans ensemble vous êtes vus 15 ans
quand gros en cumulé mais parce que la
moitié du temps j'étais en voyage lui si
on arrivait c'est comme ça que nos deux
patients est restée très forte pendant
15 ans je veux dire un parallèle terrier
pardon de vous interrompre ses cadres au
tennis on dit le match a duré quatre
heures 36 ans temps effectif de jeu ils
ont joué une heure cinquante parce que
je comprends pas régine sais c'est que
vous êtes une femme comme ça à vous
aimer la vie vous êtes des trieuses aimé
la fête
comment vous avez pu vivre ne serait-ce
que 15 ans avec son mari qui rit et
jamais il est un hymne au froid at
surgelés l'intellectuel très très sympa
je t'aime beaucoup on s'est beaucoup
amusé on a deux chiens ensemble bien à
l'origine
si c'était à refaire vous referiez votre
vie avec qui tous les hommes que vous
avez connu le calme choisirait
repprochées même tout a été
bien d'autres à son livre était très
bien mais là avec ce qui se passe mais
on aurait dû vivre tout le temps
ensemble et ça c'était impossible
1 si c'était à refaire est-ce que vous
referiez la version française de la will
survive
oui je les sept avant que la version
anglaise arrive parce que le copain qui
produisait une l'origine on était un
copain à moi il m'a donné la bande avant
moi donc les américains ont pensé que
c'est elle qui avait copié mais si
l'adaptation gloria gaynor d'accord
alors régime c'était à refaire est-ce
que vous garderiez cette couleur de
cheveux
papa c'est naturel
kostas si régine va ouvrir une boîte je
voudrais qu'elle est je ne pensais pour
moi bravo laurent voilà il prend soin -
ouvre une boîte cadeau
les familles
mais il a préparé l'émission parce que
toi il tapait un t-shirt aller c'est
lamentable
régine il a fait une boîte à ouvrir fin
juste 1000 euros de frais c'est non à
des failles et très longtemps mais vous
savez comme gilbert et depuis les chars
manges tu veux pas l'embrasser ainsi
avec plaisir
tiens tiens ici je vais vous laisser
filer déjà mais pas pour le banc test il
est très fort dans le blindage si vaste
pas parce que sinon il pourra pas
travailler demain vous partez dormir
sans mal vous répéter tous les jours je
comprends ça je connais la difficulté
donc c'est non mais il va y aller
aujourd'hui elle est obligée est assez
vite envie de rigoler car il ne répond
pas ne répond pas inquiet d'un coup là
vous partez en voiture tous les deux là
dans la ville
toi
il va la garder elle est bien cette
boîte c'est peut-être la plus belle web
qui était jamais